Today, I would like to
talk to you about something
other than relativity.
I wish I could just move
beyond the damn theory.
This is the idea I've been
missing to complete relativity,
acceleration and gravity
are the same thing.
And an astronomer can prove it.
I found you an astronomer.
Name is Freundlich.
I will never feel anything
but love for you, Mileva.
You had plenty to say
to that chesty brunette.
I have never been
unfaithful to you.
Professor Haber, have I
ever mentioned that my cousin
is Albert Einstein?
Haber, he's legendary.
Mileva makes life
at home unbearable.
Not every marriage is
meant to last forever.
He's just the kind of
man we want in the Academy.
He's a dreamer, not
a rigorous scientist.
It's an official offer.
The Prussian Academy.
I don't know if I can accept.
I can't go back to
Berlin without and answer.
I can't move to Berlin, Elsa.
There are other
people to consider.
Most importantly, my sons.
It would only be because
I want to be with you.
Is that so terrible?